The city of Amarillo, Texas, is asking folks to guess, what is this thing?
The image was captured last month at 1:25 AM,...
...by a camera set up inside the Amarillo Zoo,...
...looking out through a perimeter fence.
Is it a person with a strange hat who likes to walk at night?
City officials asked in a tweet, referring to it as a UAO.
The Unidentified Amarillo object.
Wow.
Let the guesses begin, from Fantastic Mr. Fox.
"I don't wanna live in a hole anymore."
To Rocket Raccoon from "Guardians of the Galaxy."
Oh yeah.
The camera is motion-activated,...
...and sends an alert to zoo officials when it captures something.
There were some serious theories.
The raccoon standing on its hind legs,...
...or potentially a person walking through the park,...
...that just happened to get captured in a peculiar way.
But the public's guesses were more colorful,...
...from Sonic the Hedgehog to the San Antonio Spurs coyote mascot.
Someone tweeted the movie,...
..."Dog Soldiers called and want their werewolf back."
Another poster wondered, "Is this guy on the loose?"
And, of course, there were references to Bigfoot.
Someone thought Littlefoot might be more appropriate.
There is no video, just this image.
One poster went all out to illustrate his theory,...
...it was a "coyote jumping the fence,"...
...diagrammed with anatomy like ears, tail, et cetera.
Noted.
If nothing else, all these guesses could leave folks howling.
Jeanne Moos, CNN, New York.